im september hat russland gemeinsam mit
weißrussland ein großes manöver in
seinen westlichen landesteilen
abgehalten
die aufregung und anspannung bei den
nachbarstaaten und auch in der nato war
es ja groß vermutlich auch deshalb weil
das letzte manöver im westen 2013
stattgefunden hat und wenige monate
später die annexion der gremium folgte
[Musik]
kurz zur aktuellen situation nach dem
manöver das manöver mit den titel sabbat
2017 also westen ist ordnungsgemäß
beendet worden die truppen sind
abgezogen und ihre garnisonen sowohl in
weißrussland wie auch in russland
zurückgegangen
es gab befürchtungen dass russland
dauerhaft kräfte in weißwasser
stationieren würde das hat sich nicht
bestätigt es ist daher wirklich sowie
die nato auch eingeschätzt hat das ist
hier ein signal war aber keine
tatsächliche bedrohung für sie ein
mitglieder das wirft aber die frage auf
welche zielsetzungen manöver insgesamt
verfolgen
hier könnte man eine dreiteilung
vornehmen einerseits militärische
absichten andererseits gesamtstadt wege
und drittens sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitische kurz zur
erklärung militärisch es geht darum zig
tausende soldaten zum zusammenwirken zu
bringen
es geht darum die marine die
landstreitkräfte und der
luftstreitkräfte zu koordinieren es kann
auch darum gehen neue waffensysteme zu
erproben oder neue taktiken und ein
heilverfahren gesamtstaatlich sind wir
eine stufe höher
hier werden dann schon andere
ministerien eingebunden vielleicht auch
eine territorialstreit kraft vielleicht
auch staatliche stellen andere
ministerien und wie im klassischen fall
sogar die nationalbank außen und
sicherheitspolitisch geht es immer darum
signale zu senden signale die einerseits
beruhigend sein können andererseits aber
auch sehr ihre
wenn im großen rahmen angriff geübt wird
dann wird das eher verunsichern
wer den großen rahmen verteidigung geübt
wird dann wird das er nicht solche
wellen schlagen in der externen
wahrnehmung um verunsicherungen zu
begegnen hat man im rahmen der osze eine
mechanismus eingeführt so sind übungen
an denen mehr als 9000 soldaten
teilnehmen
bereits wochen vorher den anderen
staaten mitzuteilen
übersteigt die stärke 13.000 mann so
sind nicht nur meldungen zu erstatten
sondern auch beobachter einzuladen
das hat in den letzten jahren gut
funktioniert und für ein gewisses
vertrauen unter den einzelnen staaten
führt wie könnte man das manöver kurz
bewerten es war erstens nichts
außergewöhnliches weil es in den zyklus
von manövern gepasst hat alle vier jahre
soll im westlichen militär bezirk so ein
großes manöver abgehalten werden man hat
gemeinsam mit einem anderen staat mit
weißrussland geübt und das auch
außerhalb der übungsplätze allerdings
mit einem respektabstand zu den grenzen
von mindestens 60 kilometer zur übung
stärke gibt es unterschiedliche angaben
laut russland unter 13.000 laut nato
einschätzung bis zu 100.000 das ist sehr
schwer zu überprüfen weil man ja ein
manöver auch in kleinere übungen
zerlegen kann und somit ist es sehr
schwer zu prüfen was wo dazu gezählt
wird zur übungsanlage selbst es ging
darum sich zu verteidigen also eine
krise auf dem eigenen territorium zu
bewältigen weil subversiven kräfte in
das land eingedrungen sind und eine
destabilisierung hervorrufen wichtigen
auch es war gesamtstaatlich angelegt
also nicht nur das militär sondern viele
andere stellen wurden in die übung
einbezogen und das ist schon ein
besonderer charakter wenn man über diese
art welche eindrücke bleiben daher von
diesem manöver welches fazit könnte man
ziehen
moskau hat sicher in diesem manöver alle
drei zielsetzungen verfolgt also auf
militärischer ebene gesamtstaatlicher
ebene
und internationalen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitische ebene und es hat
auch eindrucksvoll unter beweis gestellt
das ist die modernisierung der
streitkräfte und seine ausstattung
massiv voran treibt drei punkte bleiben
für mich daher über punkt 1 russland
setzt ganz massiv auf seine streitkräfte
auch als mittel der politik
punkt 2 russland stellt sich nicht nur
auf eine nicht lineare kriegführung im
ausland ein sondern auch auf eine nicht
lineare bedrohung die das eigene land
treffen kann
die würden bei uns sagen hybride
bedrohungen stehen im zentrum der
überlegungen
der dritte punkt betrifft die
internationale dimension das verhalten
und die reaktionen um das manöver haben
wie der unglaublich veranschaulicht wie
zerrüttet und zerstört fast das
vertrauensverhältnis zwischen dem westen
und russland ist es wird daher in der
nachbereitung darum gehen das militär
ist natürlich auf beiden seiten auf
allen seiten genau geschaut wird welche
erkenntnisse man gewinnen kann
politische beobachter sollten aber noch
viel stärker darauf schauen wie man
dieses vertrauensverhältnis wieder ins
lot bringen kann
[Musik]